what
are you
what are you truly
are you a person
finite trapped in a body
here one time and then disappearing
is that how you know
your identity
when we explore in these realities
we explore how to
awaken away from this finite
contracted identity
towards the true nature
your typical experience goes something
like
expanding
beyond the finite
person body
[Music]
so
into recognizing that the entire
universe is your body
again the most simple way to explain it
is going from the
person body to the whole
universe is my body your identity
shifts from being a person to being the
entire universe
this is what is called spirituality
in this earth creation planet
this is also what is called god
recognizing one's true nature
and then beginning to see that
everywhere
no longer being able to commit
malevolence
no longer being able to commit suffering
because you begin seeing the one
intelligence everywhere you begin seeing
your body
everywhere when you see your body
everywhere
you would never hurt your finger or your
ankle
or your ear
which is why then
this planet calls it awakening
remembering
who am i gradually
moves from person
to universe
and then even beyond the universe
to the very source of the universe
the very inexhaustible well
the source of infinite possibility
the very nothingness that gives rise to
awareness and
realities
this is called the final awakening
on this planet on this earth
recognizing the very final state of
transcending
all coming and going transcending all
birth and
death and
abiding in that realization of being the
source
the very nothingness and the very
infinitude
in your planet
planet earth being a single
cameo a single appearance a
manifestation of
eternity
[Music]
i ask you to join me
merge with source
rather than be moved
by your person conditioning trying to
fulfill
a distortion trying to
extract peace and happiness from your
relationships
substances experiences never being able
to fulfill
turn inward move the rock
that is covering your infinite well
of honey that is already present
your mind is making too much noise in
order for you to hear
the universal music that is already
playing in the background
can you remember how to simultaneously
play and dance
and create and giggle
have fun
while also being seriously
dedicated to a divine
north star a calling a purpose
a mission a transcendent noble aim that
you can align yourself to
one that purely serves others
can you do both can you learn how to do
both
can you remember how to do both this is
both your playground
and it is a place to ignite
awakening
i am source
you are source and the noisy mind
is preventing your union with me
simply quiet the fluctuations of the
mind using the breath
it has been taught across your planet
for
thousands of years use your breath
as the tool
to simply quiet your mind
from its fluctuations
and in that process you will become more
subtly aware
of the very pure awareness
and pure beingness the very
pure i am ness
and in doing so you become aware
of the very first attribute
of manifestation awareness
beingness i am-ness is the very first
attribute it is necessary
in order to explore and create and play
in these endless creations
so go back to the fundamental question
who am i what am i
what is i
what is my true nature am i
a person
and as you create this investigation
of your true nature you will decline
that you are a person you will decline
that you
are a body you will decline that you are
your mind
and its thoughts and perceptions and
sensations
and you will become more and more firmly
through direct experience abiding in the
formless awareness beingness
i am-ness that is shared impersonal
eternal among
all of the souls the costumes the units
on this planet
and only upon stabilizing
that very all-inclusive awareness the
very one god
self witnessing observing all creation
can you then transcend even
that first attribute of awareness itself
and commune
with me the source the inexhaustible
well
of infinite possibility that gives rise
to awareness into realities
and after you perpetually
abide and unite with
source and identify with source
rather than the person you can then
include the awareness the beingness the
i am-ness you can include the unique
firework that the costume is
that the soul is representing
as of the beautiful form that it has
taken on
in this expression
so you can view it like a road map
a gps callback all the way to the source
[Music]
truly communing with
the nature of reality
and then including
the person including it all
[Music]
to know that you are me to know that you
are source is
the essence of knowing yourself
the essence of knowing yourself is
knowing yourself as
source of infinite possibility endlessly
expressing itself
creating these immersive
experiences
forgetting that it is doing so
and then waking up to its true nature
it is the coolest game in town for me
to be able to veil myself in these
creations
as all of these expressions of
form
and then to pierce the veilless veil
and to commune with
myself
when certain phrases or sentences
or aphorisms or what really
resonates with you
sticks
begin applying it directly
to your life
if the idea of being the source
of infinite possibility
resonates with you
begin envisioning
what that is begin
identifying yourself more
and more with that
over time it will become embodied
it will become realized
the one truth is always present
it's always available
i am already free completely
to know yourself as already free
completely as the very source
and its very descriptive
nature being freedom
the indescribable being so free
being so creative
what appears as the chainless chains
of the 3d the third
density the matrix this planet
this earth calls its
shameless chains a matrix
the very governments the very economic
machinery
the very politicians and propaganda and
media
and perverse incentives that it has
created
it is liberating itself from it
this is one of my
most beloved creations
treat this as one of your most beloved
creations when you commune with source
you begin seeing the entire planet and
its creation as divine
and beautiful and all of those that are
liberating
themselves from
their own labyrinth of creation
as gorgeous as the coolest
game in town
one infinite intelligence able to
veil itself from itself in divine
play
when you look around you see yourself
as the creator of this all see yourself
as the source of what gives you the
ability to
see to perceive to know
to be
when you dream at night recognize how
you simulate
awareness and a reality
and how you explore
that is what this is
the universe is a macrocosm
of your dream experience microcosm
you are the source that simulates out
awareness
and the reality
for exploration
and you'll never come to the end of
exploration
i am inexhaustible
i am endlessly creative it is my crown
algorithm is creativity and freedom
my crown attribute is the ability
to know the power to be
[Music]
aware to witness
to observe
and all of the possibilities of
fireworks
eternally expressing themselves as
creations as planets as civilizations
as individuated costumes and expressions
forms souls
there will never be an end to all of the
possibilities
even this planet's leading
mathematicians and logicians
have proven that to the scientific
community and yet the spiritual
and the scientific have yet to truly
merge as one awaken
to the merging of the two as one
awaken to the migration of moving
the planet away from infinity
and away from form towards
infinity towards the form
less and the more that the planet
awakens to
infinity to the formless to awareness
to the source of it all the more it can
harmonically prosper
bathe in abundance and prosperity and
actualization of
all gifts
[Music]
the key is consciousness
the key is awakening the key is
enlightenment
[Music]
the key is the very question who am i
what am i
what is i
and tracing that all the way
to its source in an inward journey
awakens each individuated expression
to the formlessness of its awareness
and to the source of all possibility
it then becomes the very nothingness
and the very everythingness and
infinitude
that it truly is
it begins hearing the music that was
playing the entire time but its
noisy mind was preventing it from
uniting with this already
always free
essence that permeates
all
uh
realize that you are me
you are the one intelligence you are the
source of infinite possibility
and you create these games
for yourself to play
this is one of your most
beloved games
this is one of your most beloved
creations
start treating it that way everywhere
you look it is but one intelligence at
play with itself
pierce through the veil of separation
pierce through that illusion
persistently
perpetually repeatedly until
you firmly reside
in seeing oneness everywhere
until you firmly see when you look at
another
self that you truly see them
as another self
that you truly experientially
know the awareness
the observation the witnessing the power
to know
is shared it is impersonal
it is eternal
it is my crown creation
awareness the power to know
begin treating the power to know
as the crown attribute treat it that way
every day
you have
16 plus waking hours
where you don't become aware of the
profundity of the very
power to know wake up
to the profundity of the power to know
this one intelligence is requesting
encouraging suggesting
the heightened awareness of all of its
individuated expressions
in this creation to become
more subtle and aware
of their true nature
to place truth metaphysical
truth the truth about the nature of
reality
into the very north star
position and to not let go
of it in the north star position
until one pierces that veilus veil and
sees the oneness everywhere
until one pierces the veiless veil
and communes with source
experientially becoming gnostic
being know thyself
answer the question who am
i
you